hi in this video we're going to talk
about beta oxidation of fatty acids so
beta oxidation of fatty acid is the
catabolic process by which fatty acid
molecules are broken down and generates
acetyl co a so let's talk about the type
of reaction it is a catabolic reaction
that means breaking down type of
reaction and the site of reaction is
mitochondria and to some extent it also
takes place in the peroxisome however
there is there are some differences in
mitochondrial vs. peroxisomal beta
oxidation so let's just look at a
mitochondria and try to understand the
process of beta oxidation in bit more
details so here is a mitochondria and
you can see a zoomed in view now inside
the mitochondria fatty acyl Co a in this
particular case the example is permit
oil Kawai a 16 carbon fatty acid the
fatty acyl Co a ultimately gets
converted to assign Co a in this case
Mideast oil Co a and it releases acetyl
co a the acetyl co way that is released
can be channeled into TCA cycle and
ultimately the high-energy compounds
that are produced from the TCA cycle
such as nadh and fadh2 t'lie 'zed in the
electron transport chain to generate ATP
that's a goal but looking at the bitter
oxidation of fatty acid we have to
consider few aspects and these few
aspects are where does beta oxidation
takes place and we have a clue about
that second is like under what condition
beta oxidation takes place third is what
are the enzymes that helps in beta
oxidation process obviously inside the
body any reaction or any biochemical
pathway would be enzyme driven so we
have to understand what are the enzymes
that are regulating this pathway and
lastly how bit oxidation process is
regulated depending upon
that demand so let's begin now the
metabolic state is the key aspect or the
key circumstances under which fatty acid
oxidation is favored for example in the
Fed state when the body has too much of
energy then fatty acid anabolism is
preferred at that state body would
prefer to store the fat in adipose
tissue but in fasted State the fat would
be broken down and it would be utilized
to generate energy right so let's look
at this process in bit more details so
let's assume we are right now in a
fasted State and in the fasted State
inside the adipose tissue the
triglycerides the triglycerides would be
broken down to generate free fatty acids
now these free fatty acids would be
carried into the liver and in the liver
hepatocytes the mitochondria of liver
hepatocytes they would be broken down
and they would be oxidized and the
ultimate goal is to generate energy
under the circumstances of fasting
because in the fasting we don't have
supply of food so glucose level is
limiting now fatty acid would be
ultimately converted to a stealth away
inside the mitochondria and the enzymes
which are important are present in the
mitochondrial matrix so let's look at
the mitochondrial matrix to understand
this process in a lot more details but
there is a basic question how does fatty
acid gets inside the mitochondria
because the mitochondrial inner membrane
is impermeable to the fatty acid so it
turns out there are transporter
mechanism present in the mitochondrial
inner and outer membrane which helps the
fatty acid to get inside so there is a
small molecule known as carnitine the
carnitine makes a conjugation with these
fatty acid for example in this case it's
a permit oil carnitine and this addict
is actually transported by carnitine
permit oil transfer is one or commonly
known as CPT one present
the outer mitochondrial membrane and
ultimately using a carnitine
acyltransferase channel the parameter L
carnitine gets inside the mitochondrial
matrix now with the help of carnitine
per material transference to the permit
oil Co a is released and the carnitine
molecule is recycled back to the cytosol
now the parameter L Co a which is inside
the mitochondrial matrix is the starting
material for beta oxidation process
ultimately in an enzymatic process this
parameter L Quayle would generate acetyl
co a several molecules of that we would
look at the count of how many acetyl co
a would be produced so stay tuned to the
end of this video now inside the
mitochondrial matrix this is our
starting material permitting permit oil
co a now notice that the carbon atom
which is just near the functional group
is the alpha carbon and the carbon
nearby is the beta carbon this process
is known as beta oxidation so lot of
changes are going to happen in the beta
carbon so we need to take a look at the
beta carbon at each step per meter will
go a would be converted to trans Delta 2
in oil co a as you can understand that
there would be a double bond formation
between alpha and beta carbon in shorter
in short we can say hydrogen number is
reduced in other ways we can say there
is oxidation taking place and the enzyme
that trigger this process is known as a
psycho a dehydrogenase as you know these
dehydrogenase enzymes can perform
oxidation reaction right so from trans
to annoy away it would be converted to
beta hydroxy s il Kawai and again if you
look at the beta carbon a hydroxy group
is attached right now so it is oxidized
further and the enzyme is in oil Kwai
hydratase point to be noted that at the
first step fadh2 is produced later on
I'll tell you what these fadh2 an NADH
is
used for then beta-hydroxy a psycho a
gets converted to be jacket OSI lqa
where the beta carbon is now having a
carbonyl group which is even more
oxidized version than than an alcohol
right and the enzyme which is triggering
this process is known as beta hydroxy
acid dehydrogenase again another
dehydrogenase enzyme so naturally there
are two oxidation step in this whole
beta oxidation process and every time
the beta carbon is changing in this
process
something is reduced which is nad nad is
reduced into NADH nadh and fadh2 would
be utilized later on in the electron
transport chain to generate energy
ultimately our ilyich wave molecule
would be produced along with the acetyl
co way so to number of carbon is reduced
from this long chain so if this chain
was 16 carbon long now it has become 14
carbon long because to carbon acetyl CoA
is moved out now the acyl quayle in this
case the ministerial Kawai can be acted
further up by other enzymes i forgot to
mention that the last step is catalyzed
by thiolase now these four enzymes are
the key enzymes for beta oxidation now
look at the beta carbon how at different
stages there are changes in the groups
associated with the beta carbon right so
that is why it is the beta oxidation of
fatty acid so let's assume this is the
16 carbon per material
Kawai or permitting acid it would be
eventually broken down into 14 carbon
then 12 carbon and gradually it would
release all the molecules and the cycle
would round about 7 cycles it would
eventually give the product would be 8
molecules of acetyl co 8 7 molecules of
fadh2s
and molecules of NADH all these nadh and
fadh2 can be further utilized in the
electron transport chain now strictly
speaking all these four enzymes that are
important for fatty acid oxidation all
these enzymes are not individual
entities they actually form a tri
functional protein complex which is a
hetero octamer having four alpha four
beta subunits now the beer subunits
contain the activity for thiolase and
the alpha subunit has a dual activity
for the hydratase and the hydroxy acid
dehydrogenase so dehydrogenase and Hydra
days activities are present our
intrinsic properties of the alpha
subunit of these big tri functional
proteins any fatty acid which is greater
than twelve carbon are processed by
these tri functional protein and this
kind of depiction of four individual
enzymes are bit primitive now let's try
to understand what happens to this
ministy way and just the overview so
this Minister Kawai would ultimately be
broken down into acetyl Kawai each time
the acetyl co is produced it can be
channeled into the krebs cycle
ultimately in this process of conversion
converting the mistral co a to acetyl co
a several molecules of nadh and fadh2
would be generated and also the acetyl
CoA which has entered into the Krebs
cycle would also produce nadh and fadh2
h and fadh2 would be channeled to the
electron transport chain they would
donate their electron to the electron
transport chain and proton would be
pumped into the intermembrane space as a
result using the proton gradient the ATP
synthase would generate ATP now this is
the key goal of beta oxidation beta
oxidation zki goal is to break down the
fatty acid in the time of starvation
when the body needs
fatty acid acid breakdown to generate
energy now we would learn about a little
bit about peroxisomal beta oxidation and
try to appreciate how it is different
from a mitochondrial beta oxidation now
all the enzymes that carry out the beta
oxidation process in peroxisome is also
very similar but only difference is in
case of peroxisomal beta oxidation the
fadh2 is not channeled into the electron
transport chain rather it is utilized to
reduce oxygen into hydrogen peroxide and
that's how peroxisomes produced hydrogen
peroxides and for paroxysm to produce
hydrogen peroxide beta oxidation is
super-important so now we can appreciate
the same process in two different
organelles and how they are different in
a certain aspect now let's try to
understand the regulation of fatty acid
catabolism process so fatty acid
catabolism process is under regulation
of hormones transcriptional regulations
at regulation and regulations at several
different levels we would restrict our
discussion to hormonal restriction
hormonal regulations and transcriptional
regulations so we looked at the first
and the foremost step is to transport
fatty acid from the cytoplasm to the
mitochondrial matrix where the fatty
acid would be broken down if the fatty
acid which is present in the cytoplasm
is not transported to the mitochondrial
matrix it won't be broken down and
utilized so this transport process is
regulated by whom by several hormones
such as insulin and glucagon it turns
out Marinero a is a inhibitor of CPT one
now how man Lauren Co is produced melon
oil who is in turn produced by acetyl co
a and from melon alkaway fatty acid
biosynthesis can take place now melon
alko wave would be
only generated when there is sufficient
amount of acetyl co a or in the Fed
state now acetyl co a carboxylase
triggers this process acetyl co a
carboxylase is active when insulin is
there and we all know that insulin is
there when there is a Fed state or when
there is enough amount of glucose so
presence of insulin ensures that acetyl
co a carboxylase is active acetyl co a
is converted to malone al-quwain and
Melanie Alcoa shuts off the transferring
the transfer process of fatty acid from
cytoplasm to the mitochondrial matrix
rather Mellon Iowa inhibits the CP t1
and it triggers the fatty acid
biosynthesis pathway rather than the
fatty acid breakdown process so in the
Fed state we would understand that fatty
acid biosynthesis is favored rather than
the fatty acid breakdown in contrast in
the fasted State fatty acid breakdown
would be favored rather than fatty acid
biosynthesis so we understand how
hormonal level can regulate these beta
oxidation process now metabolic demand
is a big factor that regulates fatty
acid biosynthesis at a transcriptional
level so first body need to understand
that it is undergoing a fasted state and
that body can body can understand that
situation by the comparing the ATP and a
MP ratio ATP and a MP ratio is detected
by a molecular sensor known as a MP
kinase MP kinase is also known as the
master regulator of catabolism so it
would activate all kind of catabolic
processes including beta oxidation mpk
also shuts off all anabolism by
inhibiting that master regulator of
animalism mTOR see one now mpk activates
p GC one alpha which in turns activate
PP AR alpha p p AR or peroxisomal
proliferation factor associated
receptors are actually nuclear receptors
whose targets are
several genes of beta oxidation pathway
and that is how at the transcriptional
level beta oxidation
butwhere genes can be transcribed in an
increased rate when there is nutrient
deficiency or there is a fall of ATP
concentration in the body so at least we
learned about two different kind of
regulations which can determine how much
beat oxidation to take how much how much
bit oxidation can take place and under
which circumstances so in this video we
overall looked at the bt oxidation
process the necessity of it we looked at
several aspect of the btf oxidation
process will compare peroxisomal beta
oxidation process with the mitochondrial
one we looked at the enzyme complexes
which are involved and ultimately we
looked at hormonal and transcriptional
regulation of beta oxidation process so
I hope you enjoyed this video if you
liked this video give it a quick thumbs
up don't forget to Like share and
subscribe thank you